from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between lays and walkers in the u.s and
the uk this is food wars
we'll start with a quick note to explain
the different names walkers used to be
its own company and was the most popular
chris brand in the uk frito lay actually
acquired walkers in 1989 but they
decided to still use the brand name in
the uk so all that brand loyalty didn't
go to waste in the uk walker's crisps
come in five portion sizes a multi-pack
25 gram bag a 32.5 gram bag a 45 gram
bag a 65 gram bag and a 175 gram sharing
bag the smallest that's in the
multi-pack bag is 28 grams then we move
up to a 78 gram bag a 226 gram bag and
then our party size bag
368 grams that means our biggest bag is
110 larger than the biggest bag in the
uk
a few other things to note in the uk if
you get a flavored bag it's the same
weight as the ready salted version
whereas in the u.s our flavored bags
weigh less than the original flavored
bags take this bag of salt and vinegar
chips it weighs 7.75 ounces compared to
the classic regular salted eight ounce
bag back in 2014 pepsico claimed the
reason there is a slightly higher price
per ounce for flavor chips is the added
seasoning okay before we continue
they're telling us ways less costs more
because we're adding more seasoning
right guys well i got a question for you
pepsico
what does it say there it says lightly
salted so i understand this has less
salt than these guys
huh
closer inspection right there seven and
three fourths ounces not the folate if
there's less seasoning and salt in here
why is it a smaller ounce and a higher
price
[Laughter]
they're stealing my salt salt literally
the cheapest thing on the planet we have
a whole ocean full of it and yet they're
still skimping on it
your move pepsico this 28 grand bag of
chips supposedly has 15 chips in it
according to lei's website well they
lied about the salt what else they lied
about i'm going to count the crips in
this 25 gram bags for comparison these
chips are demolished
i didn't feel that's more than 15. this
is what we call the uh stoner math
section of food wars we do the math so
you stoners don't have to
and someone
absolute frankenstein of a crisp this
arguably not one
put together chip in here okay let's
just that's a chip that's a chip right
so the issue there is that the crisps
are all vastly different sizes like this
one just one crisp but it's tiny whereas
this one also one crisp but way bigger
and we've ended up with 22.
of all the arbitrary things we do on
this show this has to be the most
arbitrary wow look at that everyone they
gave me an extra chip 16 instead of 15.
the last thing we wanted to check was
how much air you're getting in your bags
walkers in the uk are kind of notorious
for seemingly under filling the bags
we're going to find the volume of the
bag and then the volume of the crisps
inside to find out just how much wasted
space there is what i need to do is
carefully open a bag
just enough to let the air out and then
i'm going to try and powder these like
just crush them as far as i can and then
measure the volume of the powder in this
thing
together
rumbling up
crushing backs with
oh this is like
yeah
it's quite therapeutic it feels like i'm
giving a massage
just like the world's worst massage
i need something to like kind of tamp it
down you know because the air stuck in
there so i'll just use oh i don't know
this pair of nunchucks
oh yeah
now step two is gonna be to find the
volume of the bag itself so we're gonna
fill the bag with water to try and find
the volume oh my gosh
perfect
but now i have to get it in there
without spilling everywhere
three two one go
okay oh it's perfect look at that that
went pretty well we didn't spill water
everywhere
oh my god it's like right to the top
there that's crazy how that worked okay
spooky and roomy are making a triumphant
return go and watch the res episode if
you haven't already
some of that
and then measure the rest
yeah number two
oh god
can you see like the bits of stuff
floating out of there so according to my
trusted friend percentage calculator.net
around 90
of a 25 gram walker's bag is wasted
space i don't know what the math is i'm
supposed to be figuring out i forgot
but whoever's editing this take all
those numbers and this is the conclusion
now that air
is actually there for a reason it's
nitrogen gas which helps preserve the
chips and also acts as a cushion to stop
them getting smashed in transit i mean
imagine what it'd be like if didn't have
all that air in there so as much air as
there is in there it's actually vitally
important if anything that you put more
air in these things because these things
they turn into dust into dust
there are all the walkers products from
the uk that you won't find in the us and
here is everything you can only get in
the u.s and not in the uk i am losing my
mind let's go
i'm going to start with a couple of
linguistic stylistic differences rather
than anything else for example in the uk
we call our classic walkers ready salted
as opposed to original i believe this is
a reference to the very old days of
crisps where what you would actually get
is just like a bag of plain crisp and
then you would have to add your own salt
these ones are ready salted you don't
have to add any salt it's already on
there one stylistic difference is worth
pointing out is that in the uk our salt
and vinegar chips are green i will say
walkers is like kind of the only brand
that does that and then we're onto some
actual exclusive flavors we'll start
with this one which is cheese and onion
now americans don't have cheese and
onion which might shock a few brits
because it's one of the most popular
flavors here instead they have i think
like cheddar and sour cream and sour
cream and onion it just ruins your
breath your breath smells so bad after
these how do i get so lucky i love chips
i love different flavors i love trying
new varieties and i hate paying for it
so this is perfect for me i am going to
start with a flavor that i never heard
of cheddar jalapeno
oh
oh my god
i like the kick on these it reminds me
of the cheddar and sour cream which i
can't believe you guys don't have this
flavor took over
about 20 years ago and i don't know why
it's so good but it is good
i love this flavor if i had to rank them
though i'll put the jalapeno above that
one the cheddar and sour cream sour
cream i don't even got to open these
sour cream and onion classic flavor i
mean barbecue in america is amazing i
mean this is just a classic classic
flavor
oh man fantastic but how does that
compare to sweet southern heat barbecue
southern heat
oh yeah i put these above those then we
got honey barbecue how sweet is this one
going to be
you got greedy with sweetness ooh chili
lime yeah dude i've never had these
before chilies and limes didn't really
form fantastic combination
oh i don't know how i feel about these
it's like i wasn't into them before but
now i kind of can't stop eating them
another iconic british flavor that's
also exclusive is prawn cocktail brits
became really obsessed with prawn
cocktail in like the 70s i think it was
it just became like the sort of trendy
thing to serve at dinner parties i'm not
mad about that because it is a really
tasty one it just kind of tastes like
tomatoey because it would usually serve
with like a tomato mayo worcester sauce
combination next we've got a personal
favorite of mine which is marmite crisps
god i love marmite marmite is fantastic
the slogan was you either love it or you
hate it and that does still ring true i
think for most people i'm firmly in the
lovett camp
a bit of tang from the amount of salt
that's in there fantastic crisp harry
was nice enough to send me some of his
uk exclusives which i'm going to look at
right now where do i want to start i
guess i'll start oh no
marmite i don't i don't get why people
love marmites
i mean it tastes exactly like ass i
heard millennials like that so maybe
that's a selling point for they'd
actually be like it tastes like ass
because
the kids are into that these days but i
am not then we have a couple of meaty
options which i'm surprised you guys
don't have in the states we kind of love
combining crisps and meat as it seems
starting with these roast chicken crisps
another meaty option is these which is
smoky bacon
then we have these ones which are tomato
ketchup flavoured walkers
in my opinion prawn cocktail does
ketchup better than ketchup as ketchup
and for the last of our standard crisp
flavors we have pickled onion pickled
onions another thing that's kind of
iconic to british culture in the same
way that maybe prawn cocktail or marmite
are just because it's quite traditional
to find a big jar of pickled onions or
pickled eggs in pubs and you'd have one
of those as like a bar snack while
you're drinking your pint
the complaint i often have against like
pickles and pickled onions is that
they're not tangy enough and these are
very tangy so good job walkers
puckering pickled onion what does that
mean
puckering like
like i mean kissed kissed by it kissed
by a pickled onion yo these suck
hey joe can i try some of those harry
try some of these great american flavors
thank you
let's start with the lemon that's what i
got in my hand
oh those are lemony
but i don't think i've ever had a citrus
crisp before that is not something that
we have in the uk those are good i gotta
say
love these chips
yeah
i gotta score a bag of these chesapeake
bay crab seasoning
lays oh
yeah no these are bad put these at the
bottom these are at my 7-eleven
tomato and chili flavored chips which
sounds amazing i'm going to i'm going to
pronounce this wrong sabritas
adobe and show in mexico
oh yeah dude not that spicy they remind
me kind of like a little bit like takis
look how red this is no did you think
they'd be super spicy i like that these
chip brands they're all going after each
other's throats it is just like it is
really just like guerrilla warfare you
guys don't understand what's going on in
our grocery stores in this country this
is an uneasy mafia alliance in the in
the chip in chip city
no
when it's thin like these it brings up
the flavor more of that makes sense it's
like too strong
it turns out if you put doritos cooler
around cheesening on anything it'll
taste good dill
pickle so i hate pickles
[Music]
i hate them
put these at the bottom of every list i
don't know what the flamin hot dill
pickle chips taste like but the regular
dill pickle chips are absolutely
disgusting these sound phenomenal flamin
hot dill pickle flavored crisps
match made in heaven for me you get the
heat
you get that little bit of tang to kind
of like cut through if i could take one
of these four and have them in the uk
permanently
these ones one thing walkers utilize a
lot in the uk are like promotional
flavors so currently what they've got
going on is one where they've partnered
with four different restaurants from
around the uk to showcase some different
cuisines so that means that we now have
fish and chip flavoured walkers madras
curry flavoured walkers thai green curry
flavoured walkers and chicken burrito
walkers at one point they made a cajun
squirrel flavor i'm not making that up
this one looks really good thai green
curry think i'm gonna like this
yuck
yuck rank them down fish and chips okay
i like fish and chips hang on it smells
like cat food another case i think about
dry cat food
all right i like fish and chips
i might throw up
crown it this is the worst chip i've
ever eaten the worst chip i've ever
reviewed and this might be the worst
thing i've ever tasted like i feel like
i'm on a prank show
we farted in a bag gotcha like oh you
know like in the uk walkers has a range
of baked crisps which i guess are
marketed as kind of like a healthier
option these come in four flavors salt
and vinegar
cheese and onion
sour cream and onion
prawn cocktail
we also have baked potato chip options
and one big flavor you can get here
can't get in the uk is this the bbq
baked
besides the bake there are also these
other healthier options for lay's potato
chips fans it's known as the better for
you
range of potato chips and you can't get
them in the uk you can get them here in
the u.s including these the before
mentioned lightly salted chips besides
these you can get lightly salted
barbecue
wavy lightly salted simple sea salt
thick cut and simple barbecue thick cut
if you like crunchy chips blaze also has
you covered they have their kettle
cooked series here's four of the flavors
that i could find
original
flamin hot you guys want me to open
these
these are so red these win the reddish
chip award look how red these are i like
my eyes
i like the flavor these but they're not
very hot oh wait yeah they are oh yeah
oh man but kettle cooked jalapeno
i think this whole kettle chip thing was
just a ruse to go after miss vicki's
yup they're like really similar and i
love those miss vicky chips sea salt and
vinegar sea salt and cracked pepper
other kettle cooked flavors i could not
get my hands on include the mesquite
barbecue the maui onion i would have
loved those and of course the reduced
fat original sorry i'll start with this
one which is mac's punchy paprika now
i'm surprised you guys don't have more
paprika flavoured crisps in the u.s
because it's a really good flavor i like
how they have a not actual size warning
on this bag just in case you thought
that one crisp was the size of your head
as well next up we've got sizzling flame
grilled steak max crisps now these ones
i'm interested by these are max crisps
and they are double crunch kfc zinger
flavor i think in the uk we have like a
sort of hot chicken sandwich at kfc
called the zinger burger and supposedly
these are flavored like that
little guy fieri flames on there on the
chip there yeah pretty good
see the flavor is not very strong but no
not kidding i'm the double crunch this
is like
i'm a man i'm gonna take my crunch into
the mix there like this is if the zinger
crisps somehow want enough kfc for you
then we also just have a kind of
standard kfc max crisp as well the next
one we have is this fiercely flaming hot
flavor then we've got a few max strong
crisps which i think a walker's attempt
to market to quite a specific
demographic which is uh mostly male a
little bit older and kind of like the
blokey lady types and it's just like
perfect with beer underneath like
putting the marketing to one side for a
second they come in three flavors which
are hot chicken wings fiery perry perry
and jalapeno and cheese then our final
three max flavors are these three which
are loaded cheddar and onion bold
barbecue ribs and xxl chicken and
chorizo flavored you can also get lei's
wavy chips which is their shameless
rip-off of ruffles and with wavies they
come in flavors of reduced fat original
original which i think are these i
brought the ranch
hickory barbecue salt and pepper and
lightly salted and one that i think is
limited because it says in the bag look
what i found i don't even think harry
knows i got these carnitas street tacos
wavies
hell
yes
whoa
smells good
oh it smells real good actually
oh you're not that good
trying to get flavored carnitas and
onion and cilantro and lime on a chip is
very difficult good effort guys good
attempt but i mean next up we've got
sensations which is walker's range of
slightly more up-market crisps they come
with this very sleek black packaging
they have the kind of like slightly
fancier flavor descriptions so the
classic sensations come in four flavors
which are as follows got this one which
is hickory smoked cheddar and bacon this
one which is roasted chicken and thyme
personal favorite of mine and we've got
this one which is balsamic vinegar and
caramelized onion and a firm crowd
favorite on the end here which is thai
sweet chili sensations and the finally
sensations also offer these lime and
coriander chutney poppadoms also in the
u.s you get something called stacks
which is this it's not so much i don't
think unique flavors is just a different
chip vessel
clearly lace is going after pringles i
mean they're all going after each other
these chip brands man they are cut
throat let's find out how good of a job
the stacks
do
protecting
their chips did that really do
that good of a job protecting these
chips
they're still although most of them are
broken oh buffalo wings with ranch all
right extra flamin hot yulie
ready ready to turn it up
surely you just because you're not spicy
at all whoa major let down that's extra
flaming hot and this is flammas extreme
but different colors and it's worded
differently
if you sell this color in the wild
you're in trouble turn around and run
spicy chili lamone
that's like how do we make our chips
worse on your palate and worse for the
environment ta-da stacks were born
avoid other flavors i was naturally
getting my hands on by time of filming
this bacon and cheddar potato skins
mesquite barbecue and flops
poppables which is them going after
doritos 3d doritos 3d was just doritos
going after bugles they got four flavors
i got all four i can't believe it those
flavors are sea salt
sea salt and vinegar yo what's up salty
honey barbecue
white cheddar
i don't want to try these at all but i
feel like i should
what is this
it's like a little like
chip pot
what is the point of this
i don't like
poppables we do have stacks in the uk
but they're marketed under the doritos
brand name rather than the walker's
brand name we also used to have
poppables but it seems like they've
recently been discontinued that said we
do have a bunch of other exclusive
snacks marketed under the walker's brand
name start with watsits which i think
are like our equivalent of cheetos we
used to be able to get cheetos in the uk
but then they got taken off the shelves
basically what we have are these like
baked cheesy puff snacks the standard
flavor is cheese which is this blue one
here but they also come in the form of
flamin hot and you can get both flavors
either as a small version or as a giant
version next up we've got monster munch
which are these kind of like puffed corn
maze snacks in the shape of a monster
claw and you can get them flavoured with
either pickled onion roast beef or in
flamin hot which unfortunately i
couldn't find today just like what sits
you can get them as the regular size or
as the giant size next up we've got
quavers these are like kind of like a
thin puffed curly snack and they usually
come flavored with cheese but are also
available as salt and vinegar or as
prone cocktail versions and then finally
we have squares squares are these like
very thin as you can imagine square
shaped crisps very crunchy usually quite
flavorful i quite like those and they
come in salt and vinegar cheese and
onion already salted
lace also makes dips creamy jalapeno
smooth ranch dip and of course french
onion julie says cheddar and sour cream
yeah that's really good we also have a
couple more crisp options sold under the
walker's brand name in the uk which
unfortunately we couldn't get today
these include french fries bugles and
mix-ups
are there any questionable ingredients
to look out for in your lays and walkers
chips as far as the basic salted version
of lace ships go we're fine both in the
u.s and the uk they are simply made up
of potatoes vegetable oil and salt but
when you venture into other flavors
things can get a little more interesting
for example in the uk several of our
flavors contain potassium chloride in
normal doses this is a perfectly safe
low sodium alternative to salt however
it's also one of the three ingredients
used in the three drug cocktail for
lethal injections enough potassium
chloride in your system will lead to an
irregular heartbeat and a cardiac arrest
we don't have that in our usa lays but
we do have caramel color and our
barbecue and honey barbecue chips ah
caramel color it is a widely used food
coloring it's also a controversial one
certain types of caramel color can
contain a byproduct called
4-me uppercase eye that's not an l
studies show that it caused cancer in
rats and mice leading to campaigns in
support of from banning it in foods
makes sense the fda stopped short of
banning it claiming that humans don't
come close to levels of exposure that
cause the rat's tumors sounds like a
challenge but that didn't stop the state
of california adding it to its
proposition 65 list of chemicals quote
known to the state of california to
cause cancer or reproductive toxicity
end quote another fun thing to note is
that our smoky bacon ambrose chicken
crisps are actually both suitable for
vegetarians the flavouring is just made
up of other things and doesn't include
any meat extract
[Music]
which country has the least healthy
crisps let's compare the classic first a
28 gram bag of classic lays in the u.s
contains 160 calories if we scale up the
uk's 25 gram bag to account for that
extra 3 grams 28 grams of uk ready
salted would contain 147 calories so per
gram the uk's crisps are healthier in
every metric
okay fine but what about the least
healthy chip in each country over here a
lot of them are tied at 160 calories per
28 gram bag but we did find that at the
160 calorie chips the highest fat
content are in the cheddar and sour
cream obviously the smaller bags that
makes them the least healthy the least
healthy crisps in the uk are the strong
hot chicken wings max crisps 28 grams of
these would contain
honestly my main takeaway from this is
that crisps might not be as unhealthy as
i thought they were you could eat like
10 multi-fat bags of already salted and
the only daily limit you would have
exceeded would be your fat intake yes
harry i believe that's called death by
deliciousness i live by the motto live
fast die fat and leave a salty corpse
it's actually my linkedin headline have
you ever seen that thing about how if
you look at the kfc logo it looks like a
stick man body with the head of colonel
sanders on it is there anything worse
when you're hungry and you're like i'm
gonna try something new and it stinks
you don't even stop being hungry because
you're full you're like no longer hungry
because it tasted so bad oh that's the
worst that's this i don't know if xxl is
referring to the crisps the size of the
packet or the chickens that they're
using
how red that chip looks like
[Music]